Madison is on the line Madison is in
Wisconsin that's weird
hey Madison how are you we knew Madison
was in Wisconsin but this is a different
Madison that's up Madison hi thanks for
taking my call so my boyfriend and I are
discussing marriage and the only thing
we disagree on is finances neither of us
has any debt whatsoever
so I see no problem in combining our
finances
however he prefer we keep our accounts
separate to allow each of us to have a
little freedom and they even listening
to your past conversation everyone
around this topic has included a partner
that has previously been untrustworthy
or had a ton of debt that doesn't apply
to us so what can I say to him to change
his mind Madison I'm gonna tell you
something this is one of those areas
where you've got to have a real
conversation with him because this can't
just be about each of you having freedom
because when you work together on a
budget guess what you can still have
some freedom but at the same time moving
forward with goals that you all are
united in and so I would definitely this
is a big this isn't like one of those
red flag areas for me but I would
encourage you all to continue to talk
about this and find out what else is
behind his hang-up behind it you know
the the truth is is that the study we
did for the everyday millionaires for
Christmas book when we studied 10,000
millionaires
without a doubt north of 80 percent of
them the spouses handled the money
together they were not roommates and
what he's proposing is a roommate
situation and it's listen when you can
combine and become unified on your
financial goals you're really becoming
unified on your life goals mmm
Jesus Jesus said your treasures where
your heart is and when you both agree on
that now I can I guarantee you this
the hillbilly woman I am married to has
plenty of freedom it's so and we do a
budget I can guarantee you this Rachael
Cruz who has a spending habit that she
has curbed in maturity
and our husband Winston is hardcore nerd
as far as this they work together and
Rachel says that the budget is
permission to spend then you can spend
without feeling like you're like you're
tearing down the goals of the household
or you can spend and not feel like you
wonder if when your spouse finds out
that they're going to be okay with it
you know and you know all of this it's
really bad communication to try to live
two separate financial lives so I think
if you talk to most quality marriage
counselors and certainly you talk to any
of us that have been training and
working with people and oftentimes we're
dealing with marriage problems in here
that are caused by the mishandling of
money you're gonna find that it's just
very very important relationally it is
to handle the money to Madison just sit
down talk with him again you guys you
know not having debt it's gonna set you
up to really move forward strongly and
the baby steps so I'm gonna tell you if
you're not locked in unison with this
it's only gonna lead to headache and
heartache later down the road so I love
that you all have been talking continue
to talk and dig deeper yeah I just I I
just don't see in 30 years of doing this
I'll see any data points of really the
typical marriage that is that the
marriage and the wealth are both winning
are combined right that's the typical
there's exceptions but they're rare yeah
and if she's feeling if it's if it's
someone Dave now I've coached I know you
have to some control freaks oh yeah
crazy people yeah and if that's on the
front end you need to do that get that
worked out in marriage counseling but I
think she said they're you know they're
both healthy financially that's right I
think they got a good healthy plan he's
just got this idea of you know you don't
wanna lose your identity yes that kind
of thing and you don't lose your
identity well and both have a vote
that's exactly right and he's not
getting married to have another mom he's
having a teammate yeah and so you got to
be on equal ground a man good stuff